egghead buys a cake house it's a way
psychobabble here with a main man
knowledge Trump and we're doing a
mission called I think it's Walt 71
which is discovering it in the medium of
middle school which believe is right
ahead so if you want to find it it's
gonna be right here see is the museum
witchcraft greentop nursery right here
so I think it's in the basement so let's
do this yeah yeah made in middle school
here we go here we go get good good ah
good good good now how do we get in
there you I'd ask I don't [ __ ] it now so
let's take a look I can't handle a
stupid questions and I never hear no no
no no nothing there how is that
yeah well we win again the basement you
know a lot of special things happen to
me in a basement okay my first gape my
first time I saw as a pet you know like
a lot of great things okay okay well
well well what do I am here [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
over here thank you batch good that is s
broken huh yeah yeah I can't feel your
shuts out good got we need to fray this
place let me just check her and work
with me you're not missing shut all
right shut here ok ok ok and guide now
bad me I'm going down Walt 75 that's the
mission i was talking about baby back
let's do this how's that who's making
that raucous
I can't oh shut yeah if I get an [ __ ]
take another one for me right in the
mouth all right isn't that Gunnar I just
heard you got anything where is it it's
in here
maybe you never got a card hmm I need a
card hey that's what you say huh shed a
lot of [ __ ] bodies here a lot of
bodies gonna [ __ ] is the card cigar box
don't worry I'll get it I always do just
like daddy does just like that ain't us
I probably just contato so I'd like it
oh god what is that canfil in here for
Connor I say i canna I say
[ __ ] is all this [ __ ] what is yeah it's
just like a hand thing someone's coming
that chick these [ __ ] pieces I gotta
go through stiff their dust with my
[ __ ] pans and trying to find that
that card okay I'm just gonna assume
that it'll have it ok gud get gud gud
gud gud that's ok I'll take that ok ok
let's do this where are all the people
sit access card in here nice oh here we
go that's after
no not just a bunch of [ __ ] in here okay
can I jump across to be so badass come
on yes can't get done anything yeah Nana
need to find card you [ __ ] [ __ ]
like you a check that side
hello i am the admin where are you
anything any attack [ __ ] in here oh
[ __ ] away so I thought ok Open Sesame
database ok I love Candis ok I left it
back in there not a [ __ ] waste of
time that's okay though I like wasting
time what is that good good I'll take
that I'll take justice that I could get
good good good good good good hello I'm
here to open the store
you know is that say my name it's
psychobabble say my name say my name say
my name badges it's psychobabble
[ __ ] is a [ __ ] Oh where's the Emma
I'm starting the course of study okay
what else is there I'm here for the
combat course you know that got the
access card cut cut cut Senate today
what I want I always win
okay thank you
a key the [ __ ] is has a bathroom excuse
my inappropriate
I have the access card let me and it's
like oh god got gun do the fire there's
flames okay then i say more right away
I'm here for your women I'm here for
your women okay oh [ __ ] I went too far
up no no no sorry backed out of act up
down no II know that were going down the
[ __ ] is going on here
here we go here we go last mistake yeah
man first last day
I know shed sister you think I'm afraid
of vagina I am Not Afraid of vagina oh
that yeah wait what [ __ ] i missed it
[ __ ] am I supposed to dad what is that
Oh
let's say hey let's say here oh [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] my god no one save us a
[ __ ] hour out here it's [ __ ] there we
all know that oh [ __ ] i just hit the mic
[ __ ] I you're probably ears are
[ __ ] lading ok ok ok [ __ ] happen here
now things that I've gotta get good
okay um jaysus JJ layaway cycle tile
like jeju olle Wiz [ __ ] what the [ __ ] am
I like how it does out this how about
just there and I was just sucking that
ok I'm getting [ __ ] sec here just
tell me where to [ __ ] go ok no more
mind games here we go baby here we go
activate this [ __ ] ass wipe I'll swipe
you so hard that you're bleeding
sorry that it isn't personal I just
don't like my women yes got cut stay
near stay near prime directive a cat cat
so are these subjects though okay okay
Matt mio I [ __ ] now [ __ ] kind of gun is
that it's like losing at me how can
I had that shirt hello sir I don't roll
your eyes at me okay what we did it we
did it um I hope y'all enjoyed I hope
y'all enjoyed I was just you it's in the
same nothing good waste of time
construction oh nice little bathroom and
a gardener can repair it okay well I was
it anyways well